Speaker 1: Well, today we're going to be speaking
with Mike Cargill.
Mike Cargill is running for Congress in California's
35th Congressional District.
I believe, Mike, you're the only congressional
candidate this cycle who has been an endorsed
by the Republican Party.
Is that is that a correct credential that
you have?
Speaker 4: Yes, actually, I am the only congressional
candidate in the nation who's been an endorsed
twice now by the Republican Party for being
what they consider too conservative.
Speaker 1: So give me a was there communication?
Did they tell you on what issues?
You're just too far to the right?
Speaker 4: No, actually, they scrolled we
a few weeks ago, they had an an endorsement
meeting of their board of directors.
Yeah.
And they said, here you've got 2 minutes to
talk.
And I said, Talk about what?
What do you want to talk about?
And they said, Well, watch this.
And they ruled.
4 minutes of means off of Facebook that go
all the way back to 2018.
And I knew where this came from because this
was how George Soros had attacked me in the
last cycle.
Speaker 1: Oh, Soros is going after you.
Speaker 4: He has.
And.
And so the Republican Party's using the Soros
playbook.
He came after me with Media Matters and Axios
last time tried to.
Speaker 1: Say Soros has infiltrated the Republican
establishment at this point.
Speaker 4: Yes.
Speaker 1: Wow.
So they they came after me and tried to.
Now, remember, back in 2020, this was the
world of BLM riots and things like that.
So he had unearthed a conversation, a private
conversation I had had with a friend of mine
about the use, the prevalent use of the N-word
in rap music.
And I said, That's all.
And so we're typing this out.
And I said, That's all they're doing right
now, is building the songs around the N-word.
And I typed the N-word out expressing, you
know, my concern because not.
Speaker 1: A word you would ever use other
than citing it, of course.
Speaker 4: Correct?
Correct.
But but you when you're having a conversation
in messenger, you have to type it out.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 4: And so they found this and said,
oh, look, he's a racist.
He's using the N-word.
And that was the narrative.
And The New York Times picked it up.
L.A. Times, Boston, you know, everywhere suddenly
because of the environment at that time.
Speaker 1: Well, that is so, Mike, I don't
want to let this slip because this is mind
blowing.
George Soros, who at the time of I guess when
this happened, was 90 I think he's 92.
Now, 90 year old George Soros obtained a private
text communication that you had with someone
else bemoaning the use of the N-word in rap
music.
Is that right?
Speaker 4: Yes.
Speaker 1: Wow.
That is an incredible story.
Speaker 4: And then they they take it and
they go, look, see white guy writes out the
N-word and he's a racist.
And then, you know, then they just sort of
cast.
Speaker 1: And that's it's almost unbelievable.
To be perfectly frank, I think many in my
audience will struggle to believe that.
Speaker 4: Well, it's what happened in there
was what was regurgitated by the California
Republican Party a couple of weeks ago.
Well, as as further evidence.
And they they said publicly in their meeting,
anyone can can look this up because it's all
over the Internet.
Now, what they did to me, but what they said,
how did this guy make it through the primary?
We un endorsed him in 2020 and here he is
again.
We having to, um, endorse him again.
And, Mike, listen, the country what?
Speaker 1: Just as a gut check, we're doing
this when we speak to 20, 22 candidates.
It's a weird question to ask, but I hope you'll
indulge me.
Who is the real president of the United States
right now?
Speaker 4: Well, who's sitting in the White
House?
That's the that's you know, that's Joe Biden,
right.
Was he there legitimately?
I don't know.
Let's find out.
I'm the.
I'm on a lawsuit that's at the Ninth Circuit
Court of Appeals right now.
Our oral arguments will begin September 23rd,
and we're asking to forensically audit 13
counties in California.
Most important lawsuit in the nation, is it?
And I want to get to the bottom of this question
because people go, he's not legit.
He is legit.
It was stolen.
It was a stolen, folks.
Nobody knows.
Speaker 1: Well, hold on a second, Mike.
Let's see if we can break that down, though,
because so nobody knows.
We have we have results from California, right?
The results from California are Biden got
11.1 million votes.
Trump got 6 million votes.
Overwhelming victory for by.
Those are the results we have.
In order to say we don't know, we should have
some reason to question those results.
What reason do you have to question the results
that make you say, I can't be confident that
we have the real numbers?
Speaker 4: Well, David, if you were an Olympian
and you ran a race and you got the gold medal,
let's say you're like Usain Bolt.
You run this race, you got the gold medal.
Yep.
What's the first thing they do after you set
that world record?
They do a blood test.
Okay.
And they they check to see if you have performance
enhancing drugs in your system.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Speaker 4: That's an audit.
They do an audit of your bloodstream.
Why don't we do the same thing with the greatest
race in the world, which is the U.S. presidential
election?
Speaker 1: Well, I think one reason would
be just the voter registration numbers in
California are so lopsided towards Democrats
that it's very hard to believe that there
would be any real outcome there other than
Biden easily winning.
I mean, let me ask you a question.
What do you suspect were the real results
in California?
Speaker 4: I don't know.
Speaker 1: Okay.
No, but see, but it's a copout to say you
don't know.
What reason do you have to question the results?
Speaker 4: Thousands and thousands of affidavits
that have been submitted to my co-plaintiff
under, you know, they notarized and, you know,
the charge of perjury if you lie on this that
they saw things that were not right, conducted
in a myriad of places, including the polling
places, including ballot drop off boxes.
Nobody knows.
And yet no one wants to look.
And all I'm asking with my co-plaintiffs is,
let's open the hood and let's actually see
what occurred.
Speaker 1: Okay.
You know what?
When you look at the voter registration numbers,
even if there were tens of thousands or even
hundreds of thousands of these instances.
Right.
California, only 24% of registered voters
are Republicans.
There's just no way Trump could have won.
Speaker 4: Well, I'm not I'm not saying that.
I'm saying that.
Did you know this?
Okay.
There are there are 2.8 million more registered
voters in California than there are citizens.
Speaker 1: No, that is absolutely untrue.
Speaker 4: I we've got the data to prove it,
but.
Speaker 1: I hope.
Speaker 4: You will send it to me.
My co-plaintiff is the Election Integrity
Project, California.
Okay.
Speaker 1: Well, listen, because I don't have
I mean, I've not seen that.
I mean, send it to me.
Send it to me.
You know, every state in which it has been
claimed that there are more voters than citizens.
It has been it has been debunked.
And it seems in California it wouldn't be
even close.
Speaker 4: Has any state done a forensic audit?
Speaker 1: Well, states have done all sorts
of evaluations and recounts and audits.
But then someone always.
Hold on.
Mike, hold on.
Hold on, hold.
Speaker 4: Hold on.
Speaker 1: Yes, go ahead.
Someone then comes along and says, that's
not the type of audit I meant.
Speaker 4: No.
They've done recounts.
Nobody has done an audit.
Speaker 1: In Arizona, an audit was done and
it found Biden got even more votes.
Speaker 4: The the Arizona audit was not done
properly.
What what we're looking for is this.
We have three things in our complaint.
Yeah.
Here's the ballot.
I want to look at the envelope and then let's
look at the machine.
Okay.
They've had to look at the they've safeguarded
the images of the them, the hard drives.
We have the voter rolls and let's compare
all four of those.
Speaker 1: All right.
Well, let's do that.
We're not going to be able to do it today.
So in the interest.
Speaker 4: Of we can start today.
Speaker 1: We said no.
I mean, you and I won't be able to.
Now, listen, I want to ask you something.
There's this guy who we my audience knows
him as Mike Pillow.
He's the CEO of Mypillow, Mike Lindell, but
has a shorthand, will sometimes call a mike
pillow or even just pillow.
Everybody knows who he is.
He is obsessed with the machines and he actually
wants to sue every machine.
Are you?
Where are you?
On the machines.
Speaker 4: Well, I think the machines need
to be looked at.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Speaker 4: I think just like Dennis D'Souza's
movie with 2000 mules through the ballot,
drop off boxes need to be looked at.
One of the one of the areas in our lawsuit
is the Article four, Section four of the U.S.
Constitution.
It's called the the guarantee clause.
And the federal government is supposed to
guarantee that we are free from foreign invasion,
but it doesn't say how the foreign invasion
is conducted.
And right now, we have no safeguards in California
election law to say China can't submit 30
million ballots and we have no way to safeguard
against it when they, under the guise of COVID,
have removed all the safeguards in place.
Speaker 1: But Mike, do you have reason to
believe China submitted 30 million ballots?
It's very easy to say, I can't prove to you
that it wasn't done.
You can't prove to me it wasn't done.
But do you have reason to believe China submitted
30 million ballots?
I've seen no such evidence.
Speaker 4: I don't need the evidence.
I have the Constitution, which says any law
that allows China to do this is unconstitutional.
Because it allows for foreign invasion, whether
it's at the ballot box or the shoreline.
Speaker 1: How can China submit 30 million
ballots when you have to be an American citizen
in order to even register to vote?
How how is that even possible?
Speaker 4: Because you can do it through the
ballot boxes.
No verification needed.
In California, you can have same day voter
registration.
You don't have to vote.
You can literally walk in on November 8th
and say, I've never voted in my life before
and I'd like a ballot.
Right.
Speaker 1: But if you're walking in and voting,
then you're an American citizen who who is
registering to vote.
How is China doing that?
Speaker 4: They can do that.
They can do it through the boxes, the drop
off boxes.
See, they can't deny any ballot they receive
up until the close of business November 8th.
Speaker 1: Right.
But then they look at it.
And if it's not a registered if it's not a
if it's not a citizen, then it's an invalid.
Speaker 4: How do they know it's not a citizen?
There's no checks in place.
You don't know.
They're not even allowed to ask for I.D..
They don't know if you're a citizen, a non-citizen
in California.
This is the thing.
Mike, Mike, Mike.
Speaker 1: There were 17 million votes in
California.
Okay, let's just just hear out the numbers.
There were 17 million votes in California.
Biden got 11.
Trump got six.
When you talk about any one ballot box and
you talk about China and 30 million ballots
and on and on, even if I grant you that every
one of your thousands of affidavits is bona
fide proof of some fraud.
Right?
Bona fide proof when the popular when the
voting public is only 17 million people.
How on earth do you think that they're going
to be able to slip by this number of fraudulent,
fake whatever votes and only a few thousand
people submit affidavits?
It's impossible to believe that.
Speaker 4: Well, then, would you join me in
calling for an audit of the system so.
Speaker 1: I have no reason to audit?
The numbers don't add up.
There is no reason to audit it.
Speaker 4: No.
If you won the gold medal, we would automatically
audit the race.
Speaker 1: Okay, well, there's the Olympic.
Olympic 100 meter dash is not voting.
Did you have.
No.
I mean, look, Mike, that doesn't make any
sense.
It sounds silly.
Speaker 4: It makes total sense because any
competition in the United States, if Tom Brady
uses an under a foot inflated football.
Yeah, we almost tear the country apart.
Why don't we do that for the greatest competition
in the land with this?
Speaker 1: Sounds so silly, though, Mike.
It sounds silly.
I don't know that this is going to win you
the 35th District.
I'm not sure.
Speaker 4: Well, I'm not trying to, you know,
please somebody.
I'm going to say let's get to the bottom of
this issue so that we can all be comfortable
with U.S. elections.
Once again, most.
Speaker 1: People are comfortable.
That's the thing.
When you poll people, most people are comfortable.
Speaker 4: No, that's not true.
Speaker 1: What poll do you have that?
Speaker 4: Well, the poll of my district can
I can show you that by the amount of people
who wait to go to the polling locations because
they don't trust.
Speaker 1: That's not a poll, Mike.
Most people just vote on Election Day.
That doesn't mean they don't trust another
system.
Listen, Mike, we don't have unlimited time.
There's a really other important thing I want
to ask you about, because I read the article
you do you believe that a satanic cabal is
in charge of the United States?
Speaker 4: I think there's a satanic cabal
running the world.
Hmm.
Yes.
Speaker 1: And and when you say.
Speaker 4: That like Davos and the World Economic
Forum.
Speaker 1: Who are some of the satanic individuals?
Speaker 4: Well, you've seen a few of them
already there.
They're not hiding it.
You look at any profile, high profile rap
artist you, you know, from the Clinton camp.
I believe Barack Obama has been involved in
some of it.
But you look at that, Soros is you look at
the Rockefeller types.
Hmm.
But then.
But then can.
Speaker 1: But, Mike, let's really.
I want.
Because sometimes people are so vague.
Rockefeller type.
So I mean, let me just ask you, is George
Soros demonically or say technically possessed?
Speaker 4: I don't know.
Speaker 1: You don't know.
Is Barack Obama?
I don't know.
But you just listed both of them.
Speaker 4: Have you ever asked them?
Speaker 1: No, I've not spoken.
I've never asked them.
But who am I?
But what I'm saying is.
Speaker 4: I can only look at their actions.
Speaker 1: And do you believe that their actions
are evidence of satanic possession?
Speaker 4: I don't know.
Speaker 1: But then why are you bringing their
names up?
Speaker 4: Because they're trying to destroy
humanity.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Who are the Rockefeller types you mention?
Speaker 4: Well, you've seen him.
I'm not going to get into to name dropping
right now.
I will deal with that later on.
Speaker 1: Who will deal with it, though?
It seems we would want to know if you have
the list.
I want to know who these people are.
Speaker 4: Well, if you would get me the the
Jeffrey Epstein Glenn Maxwell list, I could
probably point to a lot of them.
Speaker 1: Mike, I got to ask you a serious
question here, and I hope you don't take offense.
Are most of these satanic possessed people,
either black or Jewish, because you're naming
a lot of black and Jewish people.
Speaker 4: I don't know their ethnicity.
Speaker 1: You don't know Obama's ethnicity?
Speaker 4: Well, is he?
I don't know whether or not she claims to
be one thing and his, but he's also plain
claimed publicly to be another thing.
What do you mean?
Well, is he a U.S. citizen?
Is he an African citizen?
Is he you know.
You know, this goes back to the whole, you
know, birth certificate argument.
Oh, I don't I don't have an opinion on it.
I just know that this man has has presented
himself to be one way, and then his actions
were entirely another way.
He's been the most divisive, hate filled president
we probably had ever had until Joe Biden,
which is really Joe, you know, Obama, 3.0.
Speaker 1: Wow.
So you don't know what what about Soros and
Epstein?
Did you know that they're Jewish?
Speaker 4: I don't care.
You don't?
I don't care.
I don't care what they are.
I'm judging them by their actions more the
content of the character than the color of
the skin.
So it's a very superficial argument to bring
in.
Speaker 1: Can satanic possession be cured?
Speaker 4: Well, if you remove the possessor.
I guess so, yeah.
Speaker 1: How is that done, though?
Speaker 4: Well, biblically, it would be through
an exorcism or something of that nature.
Speaker 1: Wow.
That sounds extremely serious.
Speaker 4: Well.
Are you demonically possessed?
Speaker 1: Not that I'm aware of.
Do I seem it to you?
Speaker 4: No.
Speaker 1: Oh, well, I'm just saying it sounds
like an exorcism is very serious.
Speaker 4: Well, I would say that anyone who's
bent on destroying the human race.
Yeah.
Is probably in league with the one that you
would say is the enemy of the human race.
And that would be Satan himself.
Speaker 1: Wow.
This is bumming me out, Mike.
I'm not going to lie.
This is a sad outlook.
It's making me sad about.
About humanity.
Speaker 4: But.
But look what just occurred, David.
Yeah, we got assaulted by a virus and then
a vaccine we were misled by.
We've got a Green New Deal that's going to
destroy and collapse the US economy.
Well, that's just the US.
Look at what's going on in Europe.
Look at what's going on in Asia.
It's a concerted effort to thin the world
of humans.
Speaker 1: Dear God.
And then now, on the other end of that, what's
the goal within the world of humans?
Who benefits?
Speaker 4: Well, if you see people like you
and I in God's image as your enemy, well,
then.
Then, you know that's a victory for you.
Speaker 1: You just get rid of the of the
bad people, essentially.
Speaker 4: And enough to have sort of an army
of slaves, which is if you take communism
at its truest form, that's just a small group
of people controlling a very large group of
people through fear and dependency.
So we're looking at a world of slaves that's
being run by a few people, and they're okay.
They seem to be okay with slavery as long
as they get to be the new masters.
And that's where your color component comes
in, because it's really not color dependent.
It's who gets to play the master this time
around.
And we have, I believe, more slaves now in
the United States because of our open southern
border and our ports of entry being wide open
than we've ever had in.
My opponent is one of the chief.
Well, Chief, you know, supporters of the wide
open border and I believe is responsible for
a lot of the human trafficking that has come
out of particularly Guatemala.
But.
Speaker 1: Well, Mike, listen, I have not
seen evidence of that.
I will investigate it, I have to say, in total
honesty.
Some of this stuff is pretty out there, even
for the Republican Party.
So I sort of understand the UN endorsement.
This this is some pretty out there stuff that
you're saying.
Speaker 4: But just saying it's out there
doesn't mean it's not true.
It just means you haven't come to terms with.
Speaker 1: That's absolutely correct.
That's absolutely.
Speaker 4: Correct.
And I think we would all benefit if we would
all call for three things.
And that's that they would release the Jeffrey
Epstein tapes and they would release the Glenn
Maxwell list.
You know, how do you how do you get charged?
Speaker 1: I want to see that list.
Speaker 4: Sure.
I know with human trafficking, but there's
no perpetrators where the we know you've got
the victims, but you don't have the perps.
And then it just join me in calling for an
audit of the election system so we can put
the issue to bed.
If Joe Biden was fairly elected, I would be
the first guy to say, okay, now we've got
our our marching orders, let's fight against
it.
But if we're not if we're not going to look
under the hood and see what happened.
Yeah, then we're we're supporting cheating.
Speaker 1: Well, Mike Cargill, you've really
said it all.
We are going to be very closely watching that
race in the 35th Congressional District.
And I can't thank you enough for really giving
our audience a lot to think about, a lot to
chew on, for sure.
I appreciate your time.
Speaker 4: Thanks for having me on, David.
Any time.
I'm a I'm an open book.
And if you want to talk about anything, I
think that's the greatest problem right now
in the United States is where everyone's yelling
at each other.
Speaker 1: We must talk.
We must talk.
Speaker 4: We must talk.
And we can disagree.
But we need to do so with civil discourse.